so r3 was just announced by canon we
actually had a hands-on earlier here
today in singapore unfortunately i do
not have the camera with me in hands uh
the rules and regulations from canon
singapore are very different from what
you're gonna be seeing on the web from
probably canon usa or in europe or other
countries out there we had hands-on in
the office we were not allowed to take
any photos with the camera we could put
on our sd cards we could not take any
video footage to show you anything like
that so basically we could just walk you
through our experiences and of course we
do have some b-roll to show you how the
camera looks how it compares to the 1d
x3 and of course what it feels like in
my hands so i'm going to give you some
of the points that i experienced with
the r3 what i liked things i wish could
be improved on it in future firmware
updates and of course my overall
thoughts so let's talk about the all new
canon r3
[Music]
okay before we get into things i do want
to let you know we are not paid or
sponsored for this video my thoughts my
thoughts only so let's talk about
performance because this is going to be
the question most of you are going to be
asking does it hit 30 frames per second
and i'm going to say yes it does on most
of the rf lenses now there will be a
list of lenses on the website we don't
have that list currently right now but
from what the canon representative did
tell us most of or if not all the rf
lenses will achieve 30 frames per second
i think the macro lens maybe maybe not
but the rest of them should hit there
abouts it's a very fast camera overall i
think that's the one thing you're going
to walk away from this is that this
really replaces the one dx3 the one dx3
now is going to be
the last of the great dslrs in my
personal opinion it's a fantastic camera
i enjoyed using that camera but the r3
trumps it in every which way i would say
the only way that the 1dx still
maintains an edge over the r3 is in
terms of build quality it feels like a
piece of solid metal where the r3 is
much lighter in weight and it's a bit
smaller
but i mean if i was in war i would take
the the 1dx with me if i'm just going to
walk around the neighborhoods they're
going to do some sporting events and it
can take a little bit of a beating then
i'll take the r3 with me so that's
really the big difference between the
two but the r3 specs wise just blows it
out of the water in terms of write
speeds it comes cf express type b and of
course you have a uh s2 card slot in it
so you're gonna maximize the performance
on this camera with cf express type b so
do take note of that um it is blazing
fast you're not gonna hit that 30 frames
per second without it so don't try it
you're going to have to invest in that
card sooner or later but trust me once
you do you make that jump
it's you're never going to go back to
uhs2 to be honest with you it really is
that good
so besides the very quick autofocus you
also have this new feature called i
control af now this is something new
that we've never seen in our series
camera or any camera for that matter
it's something that i think canon is
exploring and it's interesting because
you have to calibrate your eyeball and
the way you do it is you look into the
evf and you look at various different
dots or circles at 12 o'clock 3 6 and 9
horizontal and vertical and once you do
that wherever your eye looks through the
evf there is a circle that moves around
and that sort of pinpoints where you
want to focus at
now this is a hit and miss uh feature to
be honest with you and it's still all we
were using here was pre-production they
were insane the firmware was
pre-production on this i didn't find it
to be that accurate as a matter of fact
i found that the camera recognized faces
and eyes much faster than me looking at
the person so i would say this is more
of a quote-unquote gimmick at this time
than anything else can it improve with
firmware updates i'm sure it can but
there's so many different variables
every person's eye is different how
people look around and you know as
photographers we're always looking
around the scene to see what's behind us
what's around our subject and that can
really cause a lot of issues so
personally for me this is not a feature
that i would use
but the autofocus on the camera is so
good that you really don't need it
anyway i think it's just there for more
bragging rights and maybe over time it
will get better but as of right now
you don't really need it um also let's
talk about the shutter speeds on this
because it is an electronic shutter it's
a backside illuminated cmos sensor on
this you can go up to one over one sixty
four thousands of a second
okay so you are really going to stop
motion you're not going to get that
warped image that you see on some
electronic
shutters out there it's very reminiscent
of the alpha 1 or a9 2 from sony i would
say it's more in line with the a92
slightly right in that ballpark i don't
know about the alpha one because i don't
have a camera to compare it but from the
images that we did see uh from the test
images they showed us at least that
they've taken it looks great no issues
at all with that of course you can go
silent or you can hear a little bit of a
shutter sound so you can turn that on or
off
um iso can go up to 102 400 thereabouts
you can spend up to 200 000 thereabouts
again you're never going to use 102 000
for iso but it's there they're just
touting the great low-light performance
with a backside illuminated cmos sensor
you're going to get great low-light
performance on this iso is really well
controlled for a 24 megapixel sensor on
this now speaking of the 24 megapixel
sensor um canon is touting that this has
a better resolution than their 30
megapixel sensor that was in the 5d mark
iv or even the eos r for that matter we
don't have a camera to compare it i
asked them for sample images to show me
they couldn't provide any so we're just
going based off what they said but for
reference sake here when i did test out
the uh the r6 i did find that even at 20
megapixels
it seemed to perform like a 24 megapixel
camera so if we're going to compare that
then i would say they're it's roughly
around a 30 plus megapixel in terms of
the resolution that you're going to get
out of it or at least how it looks for
that matter uh so don't worry so much
about the 24 megapixel size of it it's
the image quality that counts and i
think canon has done a great job based
on the sample images that i saw now
let's move on to the ergonomics of the
r3 and it is smaller than the 1dx it's
more compact but it feels really good in
the hand and it's actually a very light
camera when you first look at it you're
going to think that this camera
may be heavier and bulkier than what it
is but it's not it feels very good they
really concentrate on the ergonomics the
vertical grip as well as horizontally it
feels fantastic and the button layout is
very similar to the one dx3 so if you're
a professional and you want to move into
mirrorless you don't need to worry about
sort of that you know re-memorizing
where the buttons are at it's a seamless
transition which is a welcomed addition
that canon has brought to this because
sometimes with newer cameras you have to
relearn buttons relearn placement of all
that and it's pretty much
based on memory you can just feel the
camera you know exactly where everything
is at another big upgrade they gave to
the body is a flip out rotatable display
3.2 inches 4.15 million dots it is high
resolution it is beautiful to look at it
is touch interface you can really zoom
in on your subject and you can really
know if you nailed focus or not
love this display and i wish more
cameras in this segment would include a
flip out rotatable display at this high
quality like canon has let's also talk
about the multifunction hot shoe on this
because they're also sort of really uh
challenging sony in this regard you can
incorporate a microphone into this uh on
top of that you can incorporate the
flashes so they can sync to this there's
a lot of things you can do with this
multi-function hotshoe they have
released some accessories for this uh
there will be more coming in the near
future we weren't able to test much of
them out but it's a great attribute and
i actually like the cover they put on it
actually looks really cool it says
rubber cover gives it a much more of a
sleeker look than that plastic piece
they usually put in a hot shoe it
protects all the coverings on it it is
nice battery life uses the same battery
as the one dx 3 and 2 so you're good in
that regard as well uh no issues at all
you can actually charge the battery the
same way or you can charge it by a usbc
unfortunately though
you cannot charge the camera while it is
on so let's say you want to record video
like we're doing now on the r5 i cannot
plug a usbc cable in there and keep the
battery charged as i'm recording or
doing live streaming you are reliant on
the battery inside the camera this is a
misstep in my personal opinion with
canon they should allow this people do
use their cameras nowadays for live
streaming or for long long form video
this would be a welcomed edition so
hopefully they can include this in a
firmware update now speaking of video
let's talk about video performance on
this now this can shoot up to 6k 60
frames per second internally 4k 120. um
it does oversample to 6k thereabouts so
you are good in that regards um video
looks great now i did talk about runtime
because
r5 not the greatest with heat management
so canon did say that when you do set
your magic your temperature management
control to high you can achieve up to
about one hour recording on 4k and again
we didn't test it we didn't have the
luxury to test it we're going based on
what they're telling us they're about
but they did say it is much better than
the r5 and of course with the body the
way it's designed you are gonna get um
it looks like it's gonna have better
heat management anyway because it is a
much larger camera than the r5
so in that we in that regard i think for
a lot of videographers out there you
don't need 8k most of us don't need 8k
and 6k is plenty for what we're using
nowadays anyway
this is gonna be a great camera for the
videographers out there so you're gonna
get that better battery life you can
shoot 4k longer so i think for a lot of
videographers out there they're going to
enjoy this camera in that regard also
you can shoot c log 3 and it will match
for your with your various other canon
systems out there so if you want to use
this as an a cam a b cam or c cam you
can put all those cameras together c70 c
series camera r5 r6 r3 put them all
together and it's going to be a seamless
transition in that regard um ibis inside
of it same as the r5 you can do up to
eight stops if you have an rf lens with
image stabilization inside of that as
well so that's a great attribute they
were showing us images handheld at three
seconds that were attacked sharp that is
very impressive and for my personal
testing experience with the r5 and r6
the ibis is some of the best i've used
in any mirrorless camera system so i
definitely believe them in that regard
now let's talk about the evf now the evf
is actually one of the more welcomed
addition to this camera that i liked
it's large if you're wearing glasses
you're gonna really like this evf it
protrudes out a lot so your nose is not
gonna hit the screen or accidentally
touch something on the screen and it's
very large and comfortable for your eye
and it has a 5.76 million dot evf in it
so it's in up to 120 hertz refresh rate
on it so it is smooth
this is a beautiful evf very reminiscent
of the r5 it is in the r3 so if you're
into sports photography wildlife
photography
or any sort of fast action photography
you're not going to miss that optical
performance that you would get on let's
say the 1dx the at this resolution at
this frame rate you are going to be more
than happy with it let's speak about
something in terms of sports photography
for a moment because this is where this
camera is kind of aimed at now with this
great eye tracking autofocus there is
enhanced tracking with subjects so you
can do animal
bird
people
cars and helmets
so actually this is very interesting so
if you're going to be capturing
motorsport moto gp formula one and you
want to capture the driver this camera
will actually lock on and look for it
now based on the test footage they
showed us it works well but in terms of
my personal experience i wasn't able to
test this with a car on the track um or
any sort of sports for that matter but
if there is any consolation for that
when i tested the r5 and r6 when i did
do shoot sports or animals it's some of
the best tracking that i've seen in any
mirrorless camera system out there
rivaling sony sometimes bettering it in
some aspects so
they say the r3 is slightly ahead of the
r5 in that regard so
i'm excited to try this out when we get
a unit in our hands for full review so
let's talk about price for a moment this
camera is coming in around six thousand
us dollars five nine nine nine
now this really puts it along the lines
of you know the top in mirrorless camera
systems out there yes it is less
expensive than the one dx3 which is odd
because this really replaces the 1dx3
but
that's neither here nor there canon has
their own
thing with the one dx and i get it
because the one is their flagship and
this is not considered their flagship
yet they've kind of hinted towards the
r1 in the future but anyway that's a
story for another day
but this really is coming close to the
alpha one from sony and i think this is
gonna be a very big challenge for canon
because this camera doesn't come out
till november
now between now and november we also
know that the nikon z9 is going to be
coming out or we think it's going to be
coming out right so then you're going to
have an r3 a z9 and the alpha one these
will be the three big boys out of the
mirrorless full-frame camera market and
they're gonna be right in there but the
alpha one right now is about 6 500 usd
and you can get a little bit cheaper
depending on the shop that you get it
from slight discount and this is coming
around six thousand
24 megapixel up to 30 frames per second
camera
50 megapixel for 30 frames per second
camera 8k video 6k video the r3 is a
kind of a
model body with a built-in battery for
the vertical grip
the alpha one gives you the option of
having that vertical grip on it or not
for the and also the extra batteries to
it so it does make it a very interesting
um
decision for buyers out there now if
you're in the canon market you own canon
glass the r3 is a natural progression
for you okay but if you are not a canon
user
and you're deciding between two camera
systems it does get very interesting now
i will say that from my experience with
the r3 i did find
that the user interface is much easier
than sony's
i found that the button placement was a
lot easier for me to navigate and things
just worked it just made more sense in
that regard but you can't discount the
technology and what sony has done with
the alpha one
and obviously you know as cameras stay
out in the market longer prices come
down a little bit more there will be in
symptoms from all these camera
manufacturers so it's going to be a
really tough decision for a lot of you
photographers or videographers that need
a camera system like this again these
cameras are not for everyone right these
are mainly geared towards sports
wildlife uh you know fast action
photography and some videographers that
need that extra battery life you're
gonna go for something like the r3 and
the alpha one because you can have the
vertical grip on it as well but it's
going to be a very challenging thing i
personally i would have wished they
cannot drop this camera to around 5000
plus thereabouts usd i think it had been
much more competitive in that regard and
it would have really enticed a lot of
buyers to actually give the canon system
a try because here's the thing
there is no third party really no
third-party rf lenses out there to match
what canon's currently got it's not like
sigma and tamron are making lenses right
now maybe they will in the near future
but with sony you've got sony lenses
you've got sigma you've got tamron
you've got a variety of different
third-party options out there so as a
user you maybe don't need to buy the
most expensive you know g master glass
you can buy something a little bit less
expensive but with canon you're pretty
much stuck with their rf lenses which
come at a premium yes they did introduce
the new 100 to 400 and the 16 2.8 which
are much less expensive lens they do
have some you know more budget-friendly
lenses in their lineup but for the most
part
you are really going to be paying a
premium for the lenses as well so
something to take consideration for when
you're looking at this camera system but
overall i did like the r3 uh it's a
little disheartening that we weren't
able to actually take the camera out try
it out give so you should show you some
sample images even though this camera
was using the olympics they had
pre-production cameras in the office and
they didn't want us to do that so it's
just me talking to you guys but anyway i
hope these uh these points help you and
your uh buying decision if you're gonna
pick up the r3 if you're gonna wait
anyway
i liked it a lot i think it's a great
camera system a little hesitant on the
price i control af
but i think canon's got a hit on their
hands anyway those are my thoughts on
the camera let me know your thoughts in
the comment section below like always
follow us on facebook subscribe to us on
youtube like this video helps out our
channel a lot and we'll chat to you soon
take care
[Music]